the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we continue this week with and next week
our with our conversation it's really
our final conversation about the genre
forms that are at the center of the
Hollywood era with the consideration of
the Western and perhaps we should begin
by acknowledging how central the Western
is as a movie form in in the history of
American cinema before the advent of
television in the late 40s the first
American television broadcast is 1946
and we can say that television is
actually established as a social
experience in American life certainly by
the late 40s by that say 1949 or 1950
and it's through the 50s the television
spreads through the society had become
begins to supplant the movies so that
before television let's say before 1950
nearly 30% of every movie made in the
United States was a Western all the way
through the Hollywood era and and in
fact in the in the silent era them as as
as I will describe briefly again this
evening when I do a kind of mini history
of the of the of the western movie even
in the silent era it's a central form
and even after the 1950s even after the
advent of television nearly half of all
movies that we might identify as sit in
the past as historical movies were
westerns and and of course as I
suggested when I talked about the
musical the Western can be understood
along with the musical as America's as a
uniquely American form even though at a
certain point in the mid and late 1960s
certain gifted Italian directors began
to take over the Western and darken it
and throw a kind of European cynicism
into the tradition of the Western by
that time the western genre had evolved
and transformed in ways that made this
cynicism not completely unique not
totally European because a kind of
subversiveness and perspective had begun
to enter the American version of the
Western as well nonetheless the
Western the the the Western form
underwent profound transformations and
it's those transformations that I want
briefly to talk about here as an in an
introductory way and I'll return to
those to that sort of what we might call
the trajectory or the career of the
Western briefly this evening when I
introduce some comments I want to make
about John Ford and about his classic
Western the film weren't watching
tonight The Searchers I wanted to to
talk a little bit more not only about
the Western but about why the Western
might be seen as Veen signature American
form why it is so central not only to
the history of American cinema but in a
certain sense history central to the
cultural history of American society one
way to see this is to reframe the idea
I've been suggesting or through the term
this notion that at a certain point the
movies became a form of central
storytelling in the society the the form
of storytelling that that that most
Americans that more Americans than any
other form participated in and
experienced a form that I call that I've
come to label consensus narrative a kind
of story system that appeals across
social barriers and across age that that
that intends in some sense to express
what might be called the dominant or the
central values of a society we talked
about this idea I've talked about this
idea already at some length and I don't
want to spend too much time on it here
but I want to complicate those ideas one
more time by reminding you that that one
way to think about a one way to frame
this notion that the movies and it's and
and and the Western form in particular
embodied this notion of a story form
that it tends to reach the whole society
or to speak for the whole society or to
embody the central values of the whole
society is one way of understanding the
implications of that is to recognize
first of all that the Hollywood system
which is so committed to forms of genre
representation is particularly
served by by by the principles of
repetition that are inherent in the
conventions that surround the Western
even the Western the content of westerns
or the attitudes within westerns might
undergo great transformations but basic
formulas remain recognizable from the
earliest days we think about the
costumes the horses the guns and so
forth the the and and and even certain
certain basic plots and subplots that
keep returning in the Western air as
with the musical they are certainly the
genre is so robust that it has many sort
of sub forms within it so that one can
talk about westerns that involve battles
between sheep herders and and will and
ranchers or one can talk about the
westerns that are that are focused on
the laying of the Transcontinental
Railroad or one could focus on westerns
that that focus on the conflict between
white settlers and Indians
now many westerns combine a number of
these elements and there are other
subgenres we could we could describe the
very fact that that the that the that
there are these these subgenres is a
measure of how robust the system the how
robust the system became and one way to
think therefore about this idea that
I've labeled consensus narrative or or
another way to think about what I've
earlier in the course called the
cultural work of the movies or the
cultural the anthropological job that
that genre forms in general during the
Hollywood era perform is to recognize
that we can understand the specific
genre as a distilled instance of the
larger process of the movies right as a
smaller clarifying instance we can
understand it in a certain sense as a as
a forum a space of conversation a space
of discourse in which the culture
engages in a kind of ongoing
conversation you remember the terms I
used earlier barring from from the
English critic Raymond Williams I said
that we can understand that these
countries these genre forms or these
consensus forms could be said to
mobilize three different strains of
attitude and emerge
a dominant and a traditional set of
voices and that one of the explanations
for why genre Tex and the Hollywood
movie specifically and the Western in
particular are often so conflicted or
divided is precisely that they embody or
incorporate attitudes that are some
attitudes that are traditional and
old-fashioned some attitudes that are
emerging and are and challenge
traditional ideas and also what we might
call central or dominant values and then
and that not every text will balance
those elements in exactly the same way
the second point about this is to
recognize that one of the beauties of
genre one of the reasons they serve such
a fundamental cultural or
anthropological function in a society is
precisely that they go on forever but
know that we can in other words we can
think of genre forms as a kind of
ongoing continuing conversation centered
on the same formats and the same
conventions and if if the genre is
stable and if you and and if the society
produces these genre forms over decades
the genre form itself becomes a mirror
in which from which we in which we can
see reflected the changing values and
assumptions of the culture right now
this might be true of any kind of a
particular genre form in any medium but
it the reason that it has special force
when we're talking about the movies in
the 20th century in the United States is
precisely because the form is so central
to the society because so much of the
society participates in so the picture
of the society that is the ambivalent
and conflicted picture of the society
that emerges from studying these genre
forms is likely to be far more
illuminating about the larger culture
then let's say a study of a sub cultural
form like let's say like opera not that
the opera isn't worth studying and
doesn't reflect certain cultural values
too but because the opera appeals to a
particular subculture the values are
going to be narrower the kind the kinds
of assumptions of the people writing
opera and attending opera make about the
larger culture and about aesthetic
experience are are profoundly different
from the much from from the much more
dispersed and democratic
attitudes and assumption and accessible
notions that that that that animate the
creation of a consensus form of a form
that's trying to reach the whole the
whole of the culture so this is a way of
reminding you then that the study of
what we might call the sociological or
the anthropological importance of the
study of popular forms in general and of
American movies in particular the
western genre even more especially we
can think therefore of the Western as
almost as a form of a kind of national
theater a kind of repertory company in
which the same relatively a relatively
small number recognizably small number
of actors and actresses of directors and
and and and other sub specialists who
names are never remembered consumer
eight to create the film we can think of
the movies as embodying in a certain
sense and what what what what what I'm
calling the theater of a nation and I'm
bar I put the phrase in quotation marks
not because it's a fancy phrase but
because I want to call attention to the
fact that I'm actually borrowing a
phrase from a great literary historian
who wrote a book about Shakespeare's
audience and about Shakespeare's plays
and about the Public Theater of
Shakespeare's day and called that
theatre who called that that theatre the
theatre of a nation and in a certain
sense we can say that the Hollywood
system was a similar kind of theatre it
doesn't follow from this that every text
created there is a it is a noble work of
art and it's very important to recognize
that the distinction I'm making between
an anthropological perspective and an
artistic one must hold here because
because and there's another reason for
emphasizing this because the fact of the
matter is it's very hard in a course
like this especially because some of
these films are so wonderful my own
enthusiasm encourages you to like them
and I want you to like them nonetheless
it's very important to recognize that
I'm not trying to tell you a merely
triumphalist story about about how
magnificently American movies began to
sort of realise their possibilities and
dramatize experience
because in a certain fundamental sense
these consensus values are not
necessarily noble ones and the Western
is a particularly clear instance of this
in other words what I'm talking about in
a certain sense is the extent to which
these genre forms carry the lies the
prejudices the nasty qualities of a
society as as well as their ideals and
values and we can feel those elements
even though the film's themselves want
to tell uplifting stories the values
embedded in them may not be so
attractive at all and the Western is a
particularly clear instance of this a
reminder again that we don't just look
at films for aesthetic satisfaction we
don't just look at films for we don't
need to just look at films for mere
enjoyment they are they are they are
anthropological artifacts of the
greatest importance exactly because they
they they existed at such a central at
such a fundamental space in the in the
larger in the larger society why would
the Western why would the Western be
such a central forum why in some sense
could we think of the movies with its
vast wide giant screen as the ultimate
destiny of the Western I think one
explanation for the power of the Western
film because there were Western stories
and other Western formats before the
advent of film I'll talk about them in a
moment why would the film be such a
decisive space for the Western and I
think if you think about it for a moment
you'll recognize instantly why that is
the case the format of the of the movies
is particularly conducive to the sense
of grandeur and largeness spaciousness
that's characteristic of Western spaces
and of the parables of of heroism and
and town and social social creation
society creations the creation of a
particular culture or environment in the
in the wilderness the establishment of
civilization as a recurring theme in the
Western this kind of this kind of a
recurring subject is at the very heart
of what of what of what westerns do and
turn the the movies I think into a
particularly appropriate
environment for the for the largeness
and grandeur that westerns that westerns
represent but that in itself isn't quite
enough to explain why the westerns
occupy such a central place and of
course there are historical and cultural
explanations as well the first
explanation is that the movies are born
at the end of a period in which we could
say the real West actually exists in
other words the movies come in just at
the moment that the the movies actually
are still around when when the
experience of what we call the West was
still historically actual it was no it
wasn't quite in the past it represented
the period from about 1860 through 1890
and this and this is the period of the
Civil War of the whole variety of Indian
Wars of the laying of the
Transcontinental Railroad of the
California and Dakota gold rushes the
period of the range Wars I mentioned a
little while ago between the settlers
and great ranchers who wanted to keep
spaces open for their cattle and of
course we now realize it's the period
although the what the early westerns
didn't want to acknowledge this and told
a kind of opposite story the it's also
of course the era in which we
exterminate virtually but the era of
genocide against Native Americans the
extermination of the Indians and of the
Buffalo that roamed the western plains
and and even before this real West
moment was over even before it was
became a became history it had begun to
be mythologized it was mythologized
in the popular culture simultaneously
with its actual existence and there were
a whole series of forms of publication
and forms of drama that drew on the west
and stories of the west and began to
establish what we might call the the
basic conventions of the Western
mythology or the parable of the the
the parable America likes to tell itself
about the nature of the settling of the
West one of these forms were the dime
novels that appeared in the late 19th
century and into the early 20th century
available usually in in in paperback on
news at newsstands and they they some of
them were immensely popular they they
they were here's one title a very famous
one what the equivalent of a best-seller
I guess of the day published in 1882 the
lifetimes and treacherous death of Jesse
James 1882 and of course the what what
these what these dime novels did was
they took what work quasi historical
events sometimes real events and
immensely elaborated them fiction eyes
them into heroic fables of various kinds
often celebrating people like Jesse
James who may well have been outlaws and
disreputable people in actuality another
another title the illustrated lives and
adventures of Frank and Jesse James and
the younger brothers and you can imagine
what that kind of thing would have done
in addition to the two these dime novels
there were also staged performances
plays they were often for some form of
melodrama set in the Old West and
involving the the basic costumes and
accoutrements of a Western right its
pistols and cowboy hats and schoolmarms
from the east and so forth but perhaps
even more important than these two
sources and they were very powerful and
important forms of popular culture
before films that it helped establish
what we might call the mythology of the
West where the Buffalo Bill shows the
Wild Wild West shows these were
unbelievably popular and successful here
is a picture of the of a kind of flyer
that would be distributed in small so in
small towns are sometimes in larger
towns as the Wild West Show and the Wild
West Show came to town the the star of
the Wild West Show was with William Cody
Buffalo Bill he had a very modest actual
career in the West
but it was immensely elaborated by him
and his publicist into something much
grander and more remarkable buffalo bill
made his first stage appearance in 1872
in a staged melodrama called Scout of
the plains which went on a two-year tour
right and then in 1882 ten years later
he formed his own Wild West Show which
became immensely popular traveled all
over the country and then made trips to
Europe he even did one Wild West Show
before the Queen of England and it was
an immensely successful of public
enactment the basic elements of the Wild
West Show contained the essential
mythology that then moved into the
movies they often dramatized in the what
in the Wild West Show they often
dramatize a battle between white men and
Indians in which the Indians were very
treacherous and were finally defeated
they sometimes in fact in some of the
forms of the Wild West Show they
reenacted the Battle of Little Bighorn
in which at the last minute there wasn't
rescue they reversed history in it
sometimes in order to dramatize an
outcome that was more appealing to the
white audiences the Wild West the Wild
West so the Wild West Show staged
battles between cowboys and Indians and
in fact won one of the great historical
ironies a historical irony that our the
director we're looking at next week
Robert Altman actually picks up on him
one of his films called Buffalo Bill and
the Indians a film he made in the 1970s
in 1975 I think one of the shocking
things is that the button and at certain
point of at least for two years I think
one of the participants in the Wild West
shows work was work Sitting Bull was
sitting Bull himself the defeated Indian
the defeated Native American leader at
who who was now domesticated and
actually became part of the show and in
the in Altman's fictionalized version of
this episode a drunken Paul Newman plays
Buffalo Bill and he's mocked and made
fun of in some sense by a character who
represents the sitting that chief
Sitting Bull who has all the dignity
well he's almost the only character in
the film with real did
it's a subversive post Hollywood post
Hollywood era Western as you might guess
so
so the Wild West shows the Buffalo Bill
Wild West shows were essentially an
early rehearsal for what the movies
became and many of the elements of the
Wild West Show fancy roping fancy
shooting conflicts between cowboys and
Indians
the performance of various horse riding
tricks herding of cattle and so forth
all sort of contained the elements that
then moved into the movies in an even
more systematic and powerful way and
then I might mention one final source
the novel itself in the at the beginning
of the of the 20th century in 1902 one
of the best-selling novels of all time
in English was published it was a book
called The Virginian by a writer named
Owen Wister and it remains one of the
best-selling books in the history of the
United States it still sells thousands
of books every year I once found in a
used bookstore an edition of The
Virginian that were that had been
published I think 15 years after its
original publication and that edition
was I think the 50th edition of the book
was it what it went through an
incredible number of it and in fact of
the Edition I had also included
beautiful illustrations that had been
obviously were added to later editions
once the popularity of the book became
known so what we find is that the
popular culture before the advent of
movies had already in some sense created
a full-fledged mythology of the Western
and familiarized
the society with the basic attitudes
assumptions costumes and fundamental
archetypal characters who organized the
Western and there was one further thing
to emphasize this maybe the most
important thing of all what we might
call the intellectual culture it was not
only was there a real historical
background to the Western and not only
was there a profound form of popular
culture in in in theater in in public
performances like these Wild West shows
and in dime novels as well as in
literary novels a tremendous compost of
this
that already sort of establishes the
genre even before the movies arrived
there was also a final touch and this is
this is the thing that helps to explain
I think maybe more powerfully than the
other examples I've given you why the
Western had such a hole and continues in
some ways to have such a vestigial hold
on the American imagination and on
America's sense of itself and that is
what happens in what I call here the
intellectual culture in 1893 one of the
most famous historians Frederick Jackson
Turner published an essay in the
American Historical Society published an
essay in the or delivered and it
delivered a lecture and then it was
later published as an essay delivered a
lecture to the American Historical
Society and the title of the essay was
the significance of the frontier in
American history it's probably the
single most influential historical essay
about America about the American past
it's been attacked and undermined and
qualified and and its limitations have
been widely discussed over the last 25
years but it still remains in some
respects a seminal essay even when
historians are reacting against it one
of the most important central essays
about the nature of American culture and
in this article in this article
Frederick Jackson Turner argued
essentially that you he was trying to
make a case for what makes the United
States unique he was making a case for
what we've now call American
exceptionalism right a dubious
proposition but let's listen to his
argument which has as which has a good
deal of power and interest he said
essentially that the existence of free
land of a continuously receding
settlement of a continuously receding
frontier the advance of settlement
westward with European settlers always
pressing against that frontier that this
the existence of such a reality in
American life had altered inherited
notions of social class and aristocratic
government and had created a tendency
toward what Turner implied were or said
were the American ideals of
individualism
and classless nests of democracy itself
in other words the united states
according to to the Turner's argument
had a particularly open and democratic
feel because the existence of this
frontier allowed people to escape into a
new life to to to find possibilities to
escape the confinements of social class
even perhaps in some small degree of
gender although feminist historians have
have certainly shown how confining the
life of women in the West actually was
nonetheless the sense that the existence
of the frontier made the United States
our uniquely individualistic and a
uniquely free society what Turner had
done of course was define a central
historical myth for European Americans
for the white society in the United
States and we've come to recognize the
limitations of the argument then what's
the most profound obvious limitation
that occurs to instantly how about the
people who are already here one of the
things that's wrong with the turner
thesis is it's a it's a is that it's
oblivious to the existence of the Native
Americans who were who were pushed aside
by the white settlers it's a very
complex story and I don't want to
oversimplify it I don't mean that the
that the heroic white people who got in
the Conestoga wagons and who settled the
West about whom there are dozens if not
hundreds if not thousands of certainly
thousands if we account stories in all
formats of movies and books and short
stories and plays and so forth I don't
want to suggest that there was no that
there was nothing heroic or remarkable
about about that behavior there was the
in the United States is not wrong
the American culture is not wrong in
some sense to celebrate the heroism of
those people but of course as we've come
to realize and as many of our most
recent westerns openly acknowledge this
original mythology which sort of
celebrated unambiguously the sent the
white settlement of the West was
actually also in some sense an invasion
and even a genocide and the the turner
thesis doesn't even imagine that it sees
it as a triumphal reality so there were
limits terrible limits to the argument
but there's also something profoundly
helpful about the
there is a sense of spaciousness a sense
of new possibilities a greater hostility
to social class and inherited wealth in
the United States than there are in
other places and for both good and ill
the United States celebrates forms of
individualism as against communal
behavior with a kind of intensity and
compelling power that many many not just
Europeans that many many non Americans
think is excessive and think has been
reflected in some sense in in various
forms of national behavior which we
needn't discuss in detail now but you
can all imagine your own exact your own
examples so that so but to come back to
the primary point then one of the
reasons that the it's as if the movies
were sort of waiting for the Western as
if the Western form already in some
sense in fundamental ways fully formed
comes into the movies just as the movies
as the movies are born as if the two as
if the format of the movies and the
content of the Western were made for
each other in some sense and it becomes
one of the dominant one of the signature
features of American cinema one of the
fundamental aspects of what the Western
is if we think of it as a kind of
cultural mythology is that it is it
tells a founding story right it tells
the story again and again it repeats it
every time you see a Western in some
sense but every Western is implicitly a
story about the foundation of this of a
society about the creation of a
community right you know it's always
implicitly about it in many westerns
this is an exclusive topic right and and
what we can say is that this means that
the Western is the United States's form
of a kind of story that every culture
has right and the the ancient Greeks had
have had had had a founding mythology
grounded in the Iliad and the Odyssey
right and the tutor England had a
founding mythology partly promulgated by
Shakespeare in his in the history plays
that were put on in the public theater
in the in the in this in the in the
sixteenth century and and what we can
say about these founding stories is that
they are always in some sense in some
sense
fantasies or fictions but they
articulate values and assumptions that
the culture in some sense would would
like to believe about itself and that
and that and and by their reiteration by
their repetition by the telling them
again and again they instantiate these
values these assumptions about the
society in the in the in the culture as
a whole
they're very repetition is important
because one of the fundamental things
about a myth or a mythology one of the
most fundamental things about it is that
it's a collective it's a collective
story it's not made by a single person
right and and one way to think about all
westerns although that of course many of
the best westerns have the traces of
more than the traces have the imprint of
individual contributions our John for
John fort is a great director and there
are aspects of John Ford's personality
in every one of his westerns nonetheless
even the most profoundly forty and
Western is still a collaborative form
not only because Ford as a director but
because the movies are inherently
collaborative because they have so many
different people who contribute to the
creation of the whole no one even the
most powerful director could completely
control everything right the greatest
directors know how to collaborate with
their performance and their writers but
in any case it's a collaborative form to
begin with right but there's another
kind of collaboration at several other
cards what are they one of them is that
every Western is implicitly in a
conversation with every previous Western
and in that sense there's no author
right it's a Colette the story of the
American Western in that sense it's a
collective story it's a creation of the
culture
it's a create and in fact every new
version of the Western adds to the
mythology in some sense right so in that
sense we can think of genre forms
generally the Western in particular as a
as a particular kind of ongoing
recurring discourse and if you come back
again to the arguments I was making at
the beginning of our class about the way
in which the ways in which
genre forms and especially the Western
can be seen to sort of dramatize
cultural change or the or the way in
which society's attitudes may may alter
over time exactly because so many LM
genre are stable and recognizable those
that are different are easy to recognize
are easy to identify and speculate about
so that what one of the things we're
recognizing here is that in a certain
sense the very fact that this that the
mythology is open is unfinished reflects
something that's fundamental about
society - right and this is part of
Raymond Williams great insight into
culture when he said what he said was
culture is a constant mix of emergent
traditional and dominant voices it's
never over what culture is is a
conversation it's never it's never any
one fixed thing because culture is
always in process it's always changing
right and what we can say the the the
the the the value of these genre forms
and especially because the movies could
reach so widely up to even across
linguistic barriers the value of the
movies or the power of the movies as a
as a form of this kind of discourse is
over it is overwhelmingly clear exactly
because we can imagine this process this
conversation going on repeatedly over
time the recognizable elements
juxtaposed against the elements that are
not recognizable allowing for a kind of
constant process of reevaluation of
rehearsal and of rethinking right and we
can say in fact that that's one of the
deep functions that genre forms in
general play and it's one of the central
functions that the Hollywood movie plays
now try to concretize this for you this
evening in a very in a kind of it's a
kind of comic attempt but I'm gonna give
you a kind of capsule history of the
trajectory of the Western from its
earliest days from the Great Train
Robbery til to Unforgiven so the Western
the Western is a mythology
it's a mythology the fact that
mythology's themselves are open-ended
are spaces in which a society defines
and redefines its identity and its
central values makes the western movie a
particularly powerful and central
anthropological space it enacts in
different ways over and over again a
story about the founding of society and
at the end it is grounded therefore also
in a series of complex dichotomies that
are that are that are worth making clear
even though they're very obvious when
you think about what
westerns do but think about them one of
the dichotomies is the dichotomy between
what is thought to be civilized and what
is thought to be savage between
civilization and savagery another is
often between east and west in which the
East represents civilization and the
West the sad but there's an ambivalence
because the East is also a place that is
thought to be desiccated and with
lacking vitality and the West is thought
to be an authentic place that tests us
in our in our heroic largest
possibilities right so it's so and
another kind of dichotomy that is
present in virtually all westerns is a
is a dichotomy between what we might
call the claims of community the claims
of society on the one side and the
claims of the individual on the other
side right this is an especial problem
for the Western because it celebrates
American individualism so powerfully the
iconic scene of the Western in which two
men wearing guns square off against each
other and the quicker one survives that
scene of the quick draw and of the death
and the dusty street is it could be said
to be a kind of embodiment of these
values in which you have to rely on
yourself you can't run and you can't
rely on someone else you can't rely on
the government you can't rely on the
sheriff you can't rely on the police you
can't rely on your neighbors you have to
trust yourself and in fact one of the
ways you can see the power of these
Western mythology's operating as it
seems to me in some sense one of the
great divides in the United States today
over the question of guns and gun
control is partly grounded in these
myths of individualism that Western that
the Western mythology has been
promulgating since the since before the
advent of the movies right in which the
attitudes that and in fact if you listen
to even some of the most extreme forms
of gun rights advocates actually talk in
a language that we can recognize from
westerns from western movies not an
accident that one of our recent
presidents was a star in western films
and and actually remembered some films
he'd been as if they had been actual
history and I don't say that in a way to
sort of disparage poor Ronald Reagan at
all but as a way of reminding us that
the confluent the the confluence or the
confusion of actual history with these
mythological accounts of the West is a
care
heuristic feature of the American
imagination how could it be otherwise we
have been so inundated in these stories
about the West
so another dichotomy then is that
between society and the individual maybe
finally we can say a dichotomy between
culture and nature right which is the
story that's enacted again and again in
the great epic stories that every
culture sort of generates for itself one
of the most distinctive features of
these dichotomies is the divided hero
a character you'll see embodied with
great complexity in tonight's film
played by John Wayne a character who is
some the the Western hero is often seen
very ambivalently as both a savior and a
savage as someone who has the power and
authority to bring a kind of decency and
and and lawfulness to a community but
who was himself so touched by so tainted
by the very savagery that he's trying to
tame that he's often excluded from the
community once it's been created and
you'll see a wonderful instance of
complex instance of that in tonight's
film in the way the John Wayne character
at the very end of the film is in a
certain sense excluded from the
community that he has helped to defend
one way to see many of these things or
to or to clarify many of these things is
to juxtapose or maybe as a way of as a
way of crystallizing the this process
I'm talking about whereby John reform
can in some sense dramatize that
changing values I want to I want to show
you one scene and maybe I'll just end
with this scene and this is a scene from
McCabe and mrs. Miller the film you're
going to see in two weeks and a Western
that comes after the breakdown of the
Hollywood system after the movies no
longer had the responsibility or the
obligation no longer sorts saw
themselves as as having to speak to
everyone a moment of great in many ways
a extraordinary artistic freedom the
period of the early of the late 60s and
through a good part of the 1970s many
people would say it was a moment in
American cinema unrivaled for its
complexity and its richness and one of
reasons it was such a rich moment was
that the movies had been liberated from
their responsibility to talk to the
whole culture there was an irony
connected to that because they had
smaller audience right but they now but
but it gave them a kind of political
freedom a kind of moral freedom that
they hadn't had before and I want to
show you one scene one reason I'm
choosing it is because it will resonate
for you one week when we come to McCabe
and mrs. Miller
but it requires that you know one thing
the scene the iconic scene that I
mentioned earlier where two heroes or
one hero and a bad guy square off
against each other on a dusty Street
it's a draw gun might be said to be the
most recurring or the most the
quintessential Western scene although
there are others we might nominate as
almost as important and in order to
understand the scene you're about to see
you need to recognize that what lies
behind this very subversive version of
the shootout are dozens if not hundreds
of earlier scenes in which heroic
characters that we greatly admire shoot
down bad guys in the street right well
here's a scene from McCabe and mrs.
Miller of this iconic moment remember
McCabe and mrs. Miller comes after the
consensus dispensation it's now it's
free not to be a consensus form but what
one reason I want to show you this is I
hope you can recognize that what gives
this scene its power is not only it's
very brilliantly photographed and
dramatized but what gives it its power
is has ohm has very little to do with
what is what what it itself does what
grants its enormous Authority are the
dozens if not hundreds of prior scenes
with which it's in conversation against
which it is contrasting itself because
this scene of confrontation between two
individuals who has the faster gun right
is as I've suggested the iconic moment
in the Western and and it is in in the
in the heroic Western in the traditional
Western it's a heroic moment of of me of
individual self assertion in which good
conquers evil watch Robert Altman's
version of this
trying to hit trick is to make you float
we're supposed to realize he's lying he
mention them here comes the cowboy just
surfing all the prostitutes love to
[ __ ]
we're buy some socks I got one right
here
what's wrong with your socks you got off
a war I'm out running around half naked
in that whorehouse over there actually
quite a place you've been there yet take
off your boots and show me show me a
sucker
ain't gonna do that
what do you weigh that Bell for and then
just wear it well that don't make no
sense
oh good that's what I got wrong no I
mean he just can't shoot good well let
me see it
come on for you okay
and so what the scene what the scene
does is it turns on its head what we
might say are the central values or
assumptions that have lain behind such a
scene in prison in dozens if not
hundreds of prior westerns and that's a
distilled example of this process of a
conversation that goes on if it goes on
for long enough time the the content of
the conversation can virtually reverse
itself even though the genre remains
stable and that's one of the that we
might call that the genius of genre the
genius of a genre form well it has to do
with what it's a version of what I mean
when I talk about the cultural work or
the anthropological function that movies
have
you